thank you nate the great school supply
drive is back
and rocky is live at smith's who is
sponsoring this segment to find out how
the community is coming together
to help students as they head back to
school let's check in with her now hey
rocky hey jc mercedes okay i have on my
backpack i know i'm a little big for
sixth grade but i'm feeling really
nostalgic okay
we are at smith's here with bob day with
human resources and it is your first day
back
at the great for the great eight school
supply drive how does it feel to be back
so we're so excited to be able to
partnership with channel 8 again this
year
you know last year was kind of rough
with uh with really no school or that
type of thing so
we've done this in the past and we're
excited to be able to do it again all
right me too we're giving back to the
community so i'm going to hand you the
mic and i just want you to tell me
what do we need because i'm going on an
adventure all right what are you guys
looking for
okay so you know the normal pencils pens
paper those kind of supplies are always
what the what the students need
in addition to some notebooks like you
said a good backpack
is always nice to make sure that they
can carry everything to and from uh
to and from class so you know the
teachers also at this point in time are
going to appreciate paper towels
and wipes and even hand sanitizer and
that type of thing
um you know going back to school this
year that's a whole new thing that we
don't normally uh you know have to think
about but this year we definitely will
absolutely absolutely thank you that was
great you coached me through that
process pretty well so then after you
after you grab your school supplies
what do we do next so all you do then is
check out we have boxes in the front of
each one of the stores
yep just like this and so you just can
donate uh
put your donations right into the box
just like that and then in addition to
that we're also donating lunches
so you ask your checker and they can
ring up a lunch for a student
and do that right at the checks down wow
and how much does that cost
only a dollar fifty per lunch wow that's
amazing and and just typically you know
when people
are coming in here how much are they
donating what is it costing people
uh so usually if you can spend under ten
dollars and really
really outfit a student for almost the
entire year
yeah ten dollars will go a long way for
kids let's see what's already in the box
here we've got
backpacks galore i think kids are
usually most excited about the backpacks
right absolutely
and the notebooks and the folders yes
yeah because they want to pick out their
own
and kind of be individual and be able to
say hey this is
this is what i'm about definitely it
goes beyond school supplies it's about
being
you know themselves and you know
expressing their styles i guess you
could say
so this is actually going on at every
single smith in the valley right
yes it is yeah and every single store
will have a box like this at the front
of the store
to accept the donations and we'll be
doing it through the end of july
all right so july 29th today is the very
first day so come on down to your local
smiths
i'm gonna hand you the mic again tell
everybody come on out and i'm gonna go
ahead and put my items in the box
okay so yeah so let's go wait you have
to pay for those first
that's right we gotta wrap up anyways
okay okay yeah so sounds good so come on
down there
thank you guys you appreciate it you
know what got me this time she's like
throwing all this stuff
oh yeah she's taking it back for us did
you see the sign hanging up said class
of 2033
yes wow was it 33 yes 22.
no the client the kid i guess the kids
entering now would be class of 2033.
that's scary right that is really strong
oh my gosh thank you for that reality